good morning John since 1980 the cost of
college in the US has more than tripled
rising faster even than the cost of
medical care around 70 percent of
students in the US will graduate with
some amount of debt and the average
amount for those students is $29,000
that's three hundred and twelve dollars
a month for ten years of student loan
payments now there are some ways in
which you can pay less and if you're
interested in those I've put a link in
the description it's an undeniable fact
that the cost of education in America
have increased greatly and that student
loan debt is becoming a burden so what
our college is spending that extra money
on well it's complicated let's start
with the fact that since 2008 colleges
have actually been spending less money
per student but students have been
spending more money per student how's
that possible well you might remember
that in 2008 there was something of a
financial crisis a budget shrank and so
did some institutional endowments
meaning that students paid more and got
less that trend actually stretches back
even a bit farther with the top amount
being paid per student by States
happening in 2001 but of course these
costs have been increasing since way
before 2001 and colleges are spending
way more money now than they used to so
what to school spend their money well
the first thing you think of is academic
instruction and that is still the
biggest category of spend college
professors are expensive and in some
cases you're asking them to come teach
when they could be working in the
private sector for pharmaceutical
companies or investment banks and making
millions of dollars a year and you want
those really highly qualified amazing
professors teaching and so yeah
sometimes they get paid a lot the
average amount of money a college
professor makes is around 150 thousand
dollars but some professors make upwards
of a half a million dollars a year but
during the last 10 or 15 years during
which the college costs literally
doubled the cost of instruction
basically kept pace with inflation part
of the way schools have done that is by
not hiring on as many tenure-track
professors and having a ton of like
part-time and grad student and adjunct
professors who do not get paid very well
at all so the cost of instruction
overall is definitely not where this big
bump came from the costs that have
definitely increased a lot are in a
jumble of different categories that
different institutions track differently
and so are very difficult to tease out
apart from each other there has been
some really great and careful research
done on this stuff so here the increases
in a few categories operations in
groundskeeping room and board general
administration academic support and a
nebulous thing which has increased more
than any
other category among four-year
bachelor's degree programs student
services which includes everything from
concerts to intramural sports to
marketing to tutors it appears that
what's driving this is in a word sales
colleges are acting more like businesses
and treating students more like
customers schools compete with each
other and in a world where the costs are
really high anyway it starts to look a
little fuzzy when a student's deciding
between three hundred and ten dollar
payments for ten years and three hundred
and forty dollar payments it's only
thirty bucks a month and if one school
has really nice dorms that
well-supported tutoring program nice
athletic fields of super dope climbing
wall a celebrity level professor cushy
mattresses and local organic produce at
the cafeteria salad bar then both the
parents who are probably footing a big
hunk of the bill and prospective
students are likely to choose the more
expensive option some of those things
are worthwhile others don't have much
use beyond like looking pretty cool on
prospective student weekend building and
running a thirty thousand person
institution that has facilities that
outpace a quite nice Country Club is
expensive over the last ten years
non-academic employees have been hired
50% faster than academic employees at
colleges and universities top level
administrators who are responsible for
increasing that enrollment in revenue so
that there's more money for everybody to
spend their pay raises have been more
than double that of academic employees
the average school now has about one
non-academic employee for every ten
students there are some private schools
where that ratio is more like one two
three absolutely not so thing about all
of this is that it still works because
even if these do silly inflated prices
College is still a good deal money spent
on a bachelor's associate's or
professional degree yields a higher
return than the stock market even
dropping out of college after 18 months
has a higher yield in the stock market
though not as high as graduating so in a
way colleges are just working their way
up to costing as much as the value they
provide I think that we can all safely
agree that college should not be about
maximizing revenue especially for state
schools this question isn't really
whether college is a good deal it's
whether college could be a better deal
it seems a little like the increase in
spending is kind of a natural outgrowth
of a capitalist society and people
making decisions that benefit then at
least in the short term it's worth
asking if treating America's students
like customers is in the end going to be
a disservice to everyone maybe we
shouldn't be selling students and
experience maybe we should be providing
them with is
much enrichment and dare I say it
education as possible because while it
is important that college is a sound
monetary investment it is also important
possibly more important that students
get through our higher education system
knowing more about the world and about
themselves and I don't think that that
has to be a monetary thing and I
definitely don't think it needs to cost
forty thousand dollars a year I don't
know maybe I'm crazy John I'll see you
on Tuesday